[Music]
on this tuesday night major security
gaps in beijing's mandatory olympics app
anyone going to the olympics is going to
be spied upon the warning from canadian
researchers to anyone attending the
games
a potential new threat in the air this
is reckless it's dangerous and it's got
to stop fears 5g technology will put
airlines on a perilous path alberta's
justice minister dials up trouble the
phone call he made to edmonton's police
chief and the addictive vocabulary game
that's v-i-r-a-l
very easy to get into how millions are
wild for wordle
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight sophie louie
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with new concerns about
the beijing olympics and paralympics
with the opening ceremony just over two
weeks away the chinese government is
already racing to contain covid19
outbreaks and imposing measures to
ensure the games are not disrupted by
the pandemic that includes prohibiting
foreign spectators but for the
international athletes and team members
taking part in the games there's another
concern the safety of their personal
information anyone attending the games
is required to download and use the my
2022 app the university of toronto's
citizen lab looked into the security of
the app and found some red flags in our
top story tonight eric sorenson explains
what's at risk
the model for the 2022 winter olympics
hosted by china is together for a shared
future but just what might be shared is
raising alarms after a cyber security
watchdog in toronto found an app that
china requires olympic visitors to use
has serious security flaws china is
concerned with the spread of covid so
athletes and others must download the
app to transmit health and travel data
my 2022 app was studied by citizen lab
at the university of toronto which found
it has a devastating flaw where
encryption protecting users voice audio
and file transfers can be trivially
sidestepped adding that an attacker can
also display fake instructions to users
the concern is over everyday hackers and
potential surveillance and censorship by
the chinese government it showcases
anyone going to the olympics is going to
be spied upon the chinese government is
obsessed with controlling the narrative
and is showcasing
a new form of digital authoritarianism
the app must be downloaded 14 days
before leaving for the games which begin
in 17 days more than 150 canadian
athletes are scheduled to compete
this chinese promotional video calls for
the world to reunite at the games but
there is a diplomatic chill human rights
groups want china stripped of the games
for alleged abuses of the uyghurs and
others canada has joined a small number
of countries in a diplomatic boycott and
will not send officials
a state media outlet for the chinese
government dismissed concerns about the
app writing all personal information
will be encrypted to ensure privacy the
international olympic committee says the
my 2022 app is an important tool for
health monitoring that it's not
compulsory to install on cell phones and
a third-party assessment found no
critical vulnerabilities this could just
be you know sloppy software coding
i think one should always sort of take
the worst case scenario this is very
much
the surveillance state one is dealing
with in china one cyber security firm
internet 2.0 suggests olympic visitors
bring so-called burner phones disposable
for use only in china the canadian
olympic committee has already told its
team members going to china to leave
their personal devices at home
eric sorensen global news toronto
in the u.s a last-minute decision by
major cell phone companies may have
averted a potentially catastrophic
aviation crisis new 5g cellular networks
will be turned on at midnight tonight
but for now not anywhere near airports
the concern is the new technology could
interfere with aircraft systems as
jackson prescott reports it's serious
enough that canadian officials have
already taken steps to protect airports
and aircraft here
radio altimeters are a key tool for
pilots landing in bad weather measuring
distance to the runway but their use in
the sky is threatened by the
introduction of new wireless 5g
technology on the ground you're going to
have interference with a variety of
airborne interests aviation is not the
kind of industry where you try things
and you see if they work for months
airlines aircraft manufacturers and the
u.s federal aviation administration have
warned 5g radio frequencies could
interfere with critical aircraft
instruments that could lead to faulty
readings missed landings or worse a
crash 5g is now the biggest issue facing
the airline which is remarkable to say
in a world where we're still in
copenhagen with u.s wireless companies
set to flip the switch and turn on 5g at
midnight the faa ordered airlines to
stop using altimeters at more than 80
u.s airports risking thousands of
disrupted flights
several overseas carriers have canceled
service to the u.s
late tuesday major u.s telecom companies
caved agreeing to delay activating a
small number of 5g towers near airports
though they insist there's no risk of
interference 5g just adds a much larger
a more random and frankly more
disruptive layer of unreliability to
what should be
safe and reliable commercial service
there's enough concern that canadian
officials have also taken notice they've
established exclusion zones around 26
airports 5g antennas will not be allowed
or they'll have to operate at lower
power until more is known about the
risks
though 5g has successfully rolled out in
nearly 40 countries the u.s has taken
fewer precautions to protect the
aviation industry
at a time when airlines are reeling from
staffing shortages and weather delays
they warn without a long-term strategy
the introduction of high-speed wireless
services risks slowing air travel for
millions
jackson proskow global news arlington
virginia
westjet has announced a new round of
flight cancellations the airline says
it's cutting 20 percent of its scheduled
flights in february due to covet 19
staffing shortages the airline also says
government restrictions are having a
major impact on travel and are delaying
the industry's recovery westjet canceled
15 of its flights in january
tough new covet 19 restrictions are
coming to prince edward island as the
province deals with the growing spread
of omicron as of midnight tonight strict
limits will be put in place on personal
gatherings and no organized gatherings
will be allowed the province is also
shutting down gyms and indoor dining at
restaurants and schools will remain
closed to in-person learning
we had hoped that the restrictions that
we had in place
would be enough for us to slow things
down
but
it does not seem to be
losing steam here even though we all
want to be done with this kovat is not
done with us and we have to deal with
that reality
in quebec new rules went into effect
today for government-owned liquor and
cannabis stores anyone who wants to
enter must show proof of vaccination
quebec's health minister says
province-wide restrictions won't be
relaxed until the hospital situation is
under control
and some changes coming to restrictions
in bc starting thursday gyms can reopen
with coven's safety plans in place other
measures including the closure of bars
and nightclubs will remain in place for
now
well the cleanup continues after a
winter storm slammed parts of ontario
and quebec in toronto it could take all
week
more than 50 centimeters fell in some
places forcing the closure of major
roads stranding people on highways for
hours and delaying back to school plans
for some students yet again jeff semple
has more on the winter blast and the
deep dig out
people across parts of ontario and
quebec woke up to this
the calm after the storm
by tuesday afternoon some were still
stuck but things looked significantly
better than just 24 hours earlier from
windsor right up to ottawa and up to
timmins
the the province was
absolutely punished by this this
incredible
one of the heaviest most intense snow
storms in recent memory
creating carnage on the roads two people
were killed near ottawa including a tow
truck driver struck by a snow plow
another elderly man might have died too
if not for clayton maguire the
eight-year-old was watching the snow
fall through his window when he spotted
a man buried in snow
then we put him on the front porch for
art we live
then i got him hot chocolate and
blankets
the family called 9-1-1 paramedics
credit clayton for saving his life
so proud of him if it wasn't for clayton
seeing him who knows how long he would
have been stuck there
after months of pandemic isolation the
snowstorm offered plenty of reminders of
canadian kindness
even ontario's premier was out offering
rides to stranded strangers prompting a
mixed response with some noting doug
ford wasn't wearing a mask and was doing
live tv interviews while driving in a
blizzard
just trying to help them like everyone
else's it's just showing the the ontario
spirit the city of oshawa in durham
region just east of toronto was hardest
hit by yesterday's storm today they're
up to their eyeballs and snow after more
than 50 centimeters fell yesterday
i try to remember the last time i saw
this much snow especially in the city
the last time toronto saw this much snow
you guessed it back in 1999 when late
mayor mel lassman infamously called in
the military but this time torontonians
are digging themselves out and even
finding creative ways to get around
and for those keeping score toronto has
received more snow this winter than most
other canadian cities
jeff semple global news toronto
extreme cold and winter storm warnings
have been issued across the prairies
winnipeg is expecting a dangerous mix of
fresh snow and winds gusting up to 80
kilometers an hour parts of saskatchewan
are being hit with blizzard conditions
and extreme cold and in south central
alberta the snow may have tapered off
but icy temperatures have now moved in
with the wind chill it feels like -25 in
calgary today
and beyond the snow and cold alberta is
also dealing with a political storm over
actions by the province's justice
minister yesterday it emerged that casey
madu made a phone call to edmonton's
police chief after receiving a ticket
for distracted driving maru has since
been stripped of his duties while an
investigation gets underway tom vernon
joins us now from edmonton tom walk us
through what happened with that ticket
sophia was last march that casey maddu
was pulled over in a school zone in a
south edmonton constituency the officer
told him that he had seen him using his
phone now manu disputed this saying his
phone was in an inside pocket or he did
end up paying the ticket in full now
after receiving the ticket madu admits
he phoned the chief of police at the
time he was dealing with a police
surveillance scandal with the lethbridge
police and he wanted to ensure the that
he wasn't being unlawfully surveyed
himself he also wanted to raise concerns
about racial profiling both he and the
edmonton police service maintain he
didn't ask for the ticket to be
rescinded now this has at least
temporarily cost him his job premier
kenny took to twitter to say madu will
step aside until an independent review
can be completed political watchers say
madhu should have known better either he
was unaware that this was inappropriate
behavior which is bad for a justice
minister to not know that they shouldn't
be interfering in the judicial system
like this or
he knew it and he simply didn't care and
that's even worse
now tom as you mentioned the premier
says there will be an independent
investigation into that phone call but
that's not good enough for everyone
sophie the opposition wants to know
exactly who knew what and when caucus
sources say rumors of the phone call in
the ticket began circulating around the
government as far back as the calgary
stampede in july the opposition is
asking when the premier knew about this
ticket or when his office knew about
this ticket
sophie all right thanks for that tom
vernon in edmonton
in hamilton ontario two paramedics will
serve an 18-month sentence in the
community for treating a teenager's
wound as minor even though he had been
shot with a handgun they were found
guilty last year of failing to provide
the necessaries of life to yosef
al-hashnawi the 19-year-old was shot in
december of 2017 but the paramedic said
they thought he was injured by a pellet
or bb gun alhaznui died in hospital that
night
tonga cut off from the rest of the world
coming up why repairing a critical
communications cable will prove
difficult
[Music]
a third death has been confirmed in
tonga after a powerful undersea volcanic
eruption and tsunami over the weekend as
mike armstrong reports we are now
getting a better sense of the
destruction from surveillance flights
conducted by new zealand and australia
one of the things you don't see in the
images of friday's volcano is something
that happened under water the
communications cable that connected
tonga to the rest of the world was
severed these are the first images of
the aftermath taken by a military
aircraft out of new zealand that had to
make a round trip of more than 4 000
kilometers they show shorelines battered
by tsunami waves and just about
everything covered in volcanic ash
the australian air force had to make an
even longer flight it's releasing images
that show damage to the port and the
capital damage to buildings and the
reason aircraft can't land the runway at
the main airport is covered in ash the
ash is proving quite problematic the
speaker of the tongan parliament is in
new zealand he says getting that airport
reopened for aid is a priority the
latest information i have is that 60 of
the runway has been cleared
and this is done manually
i hear up to 200 volunteers are sweeping
the runway the tongan government was
able to issue a first update tuesday on
the situation it does not appear to have
been as devastating as was first feared
these are before and after satellite
images about 50 homes in the capital
were destroyed but some islands haven't
been heard from the government says
communications were cut with the rest of
the world but also in tonga itself
phones haven't been working
while ships in australia are preparing
aid there are others preparing to make
repairs to that underwater cable it's
not in deep water but it's far and it's
in the volcanic area the cable company
says the safety of the repair vessel and
the crew are a concern
mike armstrong global news
hong kong has ordered 2 000 small
animals be put down after nearly a dozen
hamsters became infected with covet 19.
the outbreak was traced back to a pet
shop worker who tested positive monday
hong kong will also stop the sale of
hamsters and the import of small mammals
people who bought hamsters from the
store after january 7 will now have to
quarantine and hand over their pets to
be euthanized hong kong's health
secretary says authorities are not
ruling out transmission between animals
and
people ahead canada's new commitment to
ukraine as russia's threat looms
the u.s is sending secretary of state
anthony blinken to ukraine as western
governments warn russia could launch an
attack at any point foreign affairs
minister melanie jolie is already
meeting with top ukrainian officials who
are asking canada for weapons to counter
russian artillery mike lacature reports
[Applause]
russia's aggression near the ukrainian
border is now more than mere saber
rattling troops conducted tactical
exercises southeast of ukraine while to
the north russian tanks rolled into
belarus as those two nations prepared to
rehearse repelling an external attack
with the threat surrounding ukraine its
foreign minister has asked canada for
military equipment we know that it is
important
to play our part in the context and
therefore we are looking at options and
will take a decision in a timely manner
canada already has a rotation of about
200 armed forces members assisting and
training ukrainian troops as part of
operation unifier but it's clear the ask
is about more capabilities not more
canadians defense analysts point out we
have plenty of rifles and radios in
inventory
but there are other needs construction
equipment uh engineering equipment
depending on the specific uh supplies
the ukrainians are looking to dig in a
lot of fortifications um so if we were
willing to take something out of our own
inventory there'd be a lot of options
the brits have supplied ukraine with
anti-tank weapons to be used defensively
while the u.s is reportedly considering
what it could send to help bolster
ukrainian troops against increasing
russian aggression this is an occasion
when nato really has to ante up its
members have to ante up and that
includes financial assistance to ukraine
it includes military assistance it's
military might but also diplomatic
determination u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken is set to meet with
ukraine's president wednesday before a
face-to-face with russia's foreign
minister friday in geneva a signal that
perhaps de-escalation is still possible
even as russian troops ramp up
operations in the region
michael couture global news ottawa
what's the deal with all those green
squares on twitter next explaining the
internet's wordle craze
[Music]
microsoft is upping its game by agreeing
to buy troubled game maker activision
blizzard in a staggering 68.7 billion
dollar deal it would be microsoft's
largest takeover ever the cash deal
includes access to hugely popular games
like candy crush and call of duty
microsoft says it's hoping to boost
competition in mobile gaming and virtual
reality technology but activision is
dealing with employees revolting over
allegations of misconduct and unequal
pay if finalized the takeover would make
microsoft the world's third largest
gaming company by revenue
and tonight we are diving into a new
online craze called wordle a free game
taking the internet by storm people are
either obsessed or totally puzzled by it
if you don't already know the
five-letter game you're probably asking
how do you play it well i'll give you
six chances to guess as mike relay
explains that's pretty much the gist
it's easy to spot a whirler in the wilds
of social media just look for the green
boxes brimming with pride
in many ways wordle is more of a craze
than a simple game one disciple called
addictive nonsense simpler no i i think
the only barrier is if you're not an
english language speaker a software
engineer named josh wardle created
wordle last fall for his wife and
friends it's a web-based program which
gives users six tries to guess a
five-letter word and there's only one
word per day
get it right and you get to post those
little green boxes for all to see
100
it is a brag
um it's i think any type of puzzle
wordle specifically it's very easy to
just say look how well i am at this i'm
aka must be smarter than you in november
there were 90 people using it today it's
in the millions in part because late
night host jimmy fallon became so
obsessed
app
at
he spent 10 minutes one show trying to
solve the puzzle
the appeal is in its simplicity there
are no ads it takes under 10 minutes to
complete it's free and the worldlers
want to keep it that way
when another programmer tried to launch
a copycat app the backlash was so
intense apple pulled the imitator from
the app store
but here's the thing the idea isn't
entirely new vol violi vol v-o-l-e
there's a game show called lingo which
is itself a copy of a game created over
a century ago by austrian philosopher
ludwig wittgenstein
but wordler should already know that
because you know the best players are
pretty much geniuses right sophie
mike trolley global news toronto
very true thank you mike that is global
national for this tuesday night i am
sophie louie tonight's your canada is a
view of lake saint louis from point
claire quebec there are beautiful spots
all over canada email your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching and have a good
night
[Music]